It is abso fucking
lutely delusional to depend on a man for financial security,
and I don't give a fuck how many women get upset about it.
Is the truth. Not my fucking words.
Read the comment. Not my fucking words.
Read the comment. I'm not the only fucking one out here saying this.
I'm not the only one trying to make some fucking sense of it.
Sometimes your good friend,
what they do is they fucking grab you and shake you and be like, bitch,
wake up! That's all I'm trying to do.
I'm not the only one out here saying it.
There wouldn't be a chorus of women
back up singing, you know,
chanting about the problem if it wasn't a fucking problem.
You know, if the stay at home mom tried wife bullshit was so great,
women would not have fought to change it.
They wouldn't have fought.
If it sounds too good to be true,
it usually is. So sorry to break it to you ladies,
it's called manipulation and lies.
Don't depend on a man for your fucking existence.